motion for debate
the 75th anniversary of the arrival of
the Windrush generation
Lord Mario Bloodworth
in my laws it is a great privilege and
honor
to represent the government at this
debate on a topic that matters so deeply
to us all
we have over the last few days and weeks
been making and marking a supremely
special moment in our history
the people who arrived in Britain that
June day 75 years ago
and in the months and years that
followed are an essential part of our
national story
one can only imagine the sense of
excitement anticipation and apprehension
of those aboard HMT Empire Windrush as
they felt as approaching Tilbury and as
they disembarked
there would be hardships and obstacles
to overcome
but through sacrifice
endurance
and an indomitable Spirit overcome they
did
and in so doing they played an
invaluable role in rebuilding our
country and our public services in the
aftermath of the second World War
they were as his majesty the king put it
so aptly pioneers
what has become known as Windrush day
was a hugely significant milestone for
those beginning their new lives here
but there is meaning to be found not
just for them but for all of them for
all of us in that day
this was a seminal moment in our
Collective history
a symbol of the diversity that is a
defining feature of our society
the Windrush generation their children
and grandchildren have enhanced and
enriched our society in Myriad ways
we see it everywhere in sport culture
art business Politics the National
Health Service Emergency Services the
list goes on
so vast and so sweeping has been their
contribution that it would be a Fool's
errand for me to attempt to do it
justice in the relatively modest amount
of time available to me
instead I will simply say this
we owe the members of the Windrush
generation a huge debt
our country would be greatly diminished
if they had not come here three-quarters
of a century ago
it is right that we cherish them
it is right that we recognize them not
only for all they have contributed and
done but also for what Windrush
signifies
there are all sorts of ways we can do
that of course
this year's commemorations have been
especially significant as we Mark the
75th anniversary
it has been very special indeed to see
the Windrush stories showcased so
prominently through events documentaries
articles exhibitions and much more
above all it is through hearing and
reading the accounts of those who were
part of this unique story that one gets
a true sense of their accomplishments
the anniversary has been joyous and
poignant in equal measure
and I sincerely hope
those being celebrated feel their voices
have been heard and their contributions
recognized
the government has supported that effort
through educational arts and sporting
projects
and activities across the United Kingdom
of course remembrance and recognition
need not to be confined to anniversaries
we now have a magnificent national
Windrush Monument following its
unveiling at Waterloo Station last year
the government was delighted to provide
funding for the project which stands as
a permanent tribute to the Windrush
generation and their descendants
and a powerful reminder of their
contribution for the millions of people
who pass through one of our busiest
stations every year
many many people have helped to make the
memorial a reality
I am grateful to every one of them but
it would be remiss of me not to single
out the contribution of the noble
baroness lady Benjamin
this is of course a subject of deep
personal resonance for her
and I'm sure the whole house will join
me in commending her not only for her
work on the memorial but on Windrush
generally
my Lord the story of the Windrush
generation is uplifting and
inspirational
a story of struggles overcome
of resilience through adversity
the story should come to include a
chapter of suffering and distress in
recent years is a source of profound
sadness for us all
the terrible injustices that have come
to light shocked the whole country to
its core
what happened to the victims of the
Windrush Scandal was an outrage
it should never have happened
the effects remain painful and difficult
my department the home office and indeed
the whole government
is absolutely determined to right the
wrongs
and although compensation cannot undo
the hurt that was caused
it was right that the government put in
place schemes to provide documentation
and to provide compensation
and I repeat the promises made by
successive home secretaries that those
schemes will not close
we have paid or offered more than 75
million pounds in compensation
we have provided documents to thousands
to enable them to document their status
while writing the wrongs will remain a
key Focus for the government I know that
some representatives of that generation
are Keen for the name Windrush to be
reclaimed from the taint of that scandal
they want to see it returned to its
original status as a symbol of all that
is great about that generation and their
descendants
a symbol a strong and as visible as the
wonderful Monument I spoke of a moment
ago
this debate is an opportunity to reflect
on all that the Windrush generation
their relatives and their communities
have done for our country
it is an opportunity to celebrate the
75th anniversary of the arrival of that
ship
a ship of hopes dreams and opportunities
we are here to celebrate and thank those
who came to work in the NHS then as now
a social Innovation like no other
and one that is of course enjoying its
own 75th Jubilee
we are here to celebrate and thank those
who came to revive the post-war
transport and Industrial infrastructure
without which this country would not
have flourished in the second half of
that century
we are here to celebrate and thank those
who brought new vibrancy and artistic
energy to enrich our cultural landscape
and whose contributions have helped make
Great Britain a world leader in the Arts
and we know that members and descendants
of that Windrush generation
continue to serve their country in many
guises including in the police and fire
Services education the care sector and
social work
and we see other contributions made to
our economy our social Fabric and our
futures whether as businesses and
Technology leaders artists musicians
scientists designers and researchers and
in sport and charity work
our spiritual lives have been enhanced
by the churches Faith groups and
religious leadership provided by members
of that community and their relatives
by choosing to serve others every
generation inspires and encourages the
next
and strengthens the bonds between us all
I look forward to a debate befitting the
significance of this anniversary as we
celebrate the undeniable achievements of
the Windrush generation and subsequent
Generations
I know we will hear heartfelt and
insightful contributions across the
house
that being the case rest assured I will
very shortly take my seat
but before I do I want to quote from an
immensely powerful poem by Professor
Laura serant
you called
and we came she waits
my lords that is exactly right we called
they came and I will ever be grateful
that they did I beg to move
the question is that this motion be
agreed to
Milos I'm very grateful to the noble or
the minister for bringing forward this
debate and if I may say so for the tone
in which he opened it it is right that
this house should take note
of this important anniversary of the
arrival of the the Windrush generation
this is as the noble Lord the minister
has said a moment to celebrate an
enormous contribution of so many who
came to rebuild Britain after the second
World War
notwithstanding complex Colonial history
and a mixed welcome they came as some of
the most loyal and patriotic British
subjects
to work in rnhs
in construction
transport and as the noble order said
other vital Public Services
often it has to be remembered in
undervalued and back-breaking employment
but we must also reflect as the noble or
the minister has done
on the Betrayal of their children
in one of the worst scandals in British
history
in which inhumanity and illegality on
the part of government cost people jobs
homes Health Care Liberty and saw some
of them forcibly transported to far away
islands that some had never known in
their adult lives
despite lives of hard work and service
to the United Kingdom
many died brokenhearted and still
uncompensated
some are uncompensated still
and I'm grateful to the noble Lord
for his update but I hope the noble lady
the minister will take the opportunity
to perhaps go further on ongoing plans
to right that wrong and to do so for all
outstanding claims
very very quickly
what is his Majesty's government's
estimate of outstanding claims for
compensation what Prospect is there of
resolving all such claims this year or
before the next anniversary
my Lord's preparing for this debate gave
me the opportunity to return to Amelia
gentleman's
fine book which will shortly be returned
to
um to your Lordships Library
the Windrush betrayal records not just
outstanding and persistent independent
journalism
but the real human stories of Paulette
Wilson who had worked in catering in the
other place
Anthony Bryan Sarah O'Connor and
countless others
and their lives
devastated by a toxic cocktail my lord
of culture War cruelty and incompetence
which we must never repeat
I commend the book to all Noble Lords
particularly those with a close interest
in the workings of the home Department
I remind your Lordships that the
background to that scandal
the scandal of demanding papers of
people who had come to this country as
children 50 plus years earlier
was called the hostile environment
a policy of targets
which will always penalize the lowest
hanging fruit a policy my lords of
deterrence
people who had evidence of working and
paying tax for decades were detained and
even removed whilst their Landing cards
were destroyed in the annals of the home
office
it is incumbent
on those who speak from this particular
sport
always to mention ships
today that task is easy
however nonetheless my Noble friendly
Admiral reminds me that the Empire
Windrush brought not only Caribbean
britons but a number of Polish refugees
to these Shores
and they were rightly at the time
rightly welcomed by the then government
whilst the refugee convention was still
being settled and negotiated
today my lords the refrain is a little
different
the refrain is stopped the boats a
universal aspiration that should be
striven for with Justice and compassion
so that human beings are never again
relegated to statistics with all the
consequences that will necessarily
follow
so debate the votes by all means my
lords but never never let us forget the
stories of those who came in ships
foreign
I want to thank the government for
having this important celebration debate
and for their commitment to Windrush 75
which they have shown across many
departments and I want to thank the
noble Lord the minister for his kind
remarks
my lords five years ago when we
celebrated the 70th anniversary of
Windrush not many people knew what
Windrush meant
fast forward 7th to the 75th anniversary
and things have completely different
which shows progress is being made every
News Channel media outlet and numerous
magazines covered the anniversary they
couldn't get enough of wind Rush the
Scandal brought it to their attention
and this was partly due to the creation
of the national Windrush day the 22nd of
June which was a result of the
hard-fought 30-year campaign led by the
late Sam King MBE a Windrush Pioneer and
also the national Windrush Monument
created to recognize and acknowledge the
contribution made by Caribbean people to
Britain which the minister highlighted
my lords I was honored and privileged to
share the Windrush commemoration
committee responsible for overseeing
that historic creation
this enormous task was a labor of love
it took four hard challenging years
littered with many obstacles and setback
but with total commitment and doggy
determination a 12-foot High magnificent
Monument which was designed by the
world-renowned Jamaican artist basil
Watson was delivered and unveiled at
Waterloo Station last year on Windrush
day
by the last two known living Windrush
Pioneers from 1949 Alfred Gardner and
John Richards and their descendants
my lords the monument has quickly become
a landmark a network rail led a 75th
Anniversary commemoration event there to
celebrate their links with the Windrush
generation and lay the REITs in their
honor
my loads the Empire Windrush was not the
first ship to bring Caribbeans to the
motherland in 1948 but it's become a
symbol of that Quest under thousands who
followed up until 1973 also showed great
loyalty courage bravery resilience
dignity pride and fortitude
despite facing rejection
humiliation violence death hatred
they came with hope and optimism in
their hearts
many Caribbean people who visit the
monument at Waterloo are moved to tears
and overcome with emotion as it invokes
memories of the treatment they received
when they arrived in Britain
it's become a place of Solace
some say they wish their deceased
relatives were still alive to see this
momentous symbol many say meet me by the
monument
my lords I am powered of that lived
Windrush experience because I came to
England in 1960 as a 10 year old
traveling from Trinidad my ship then by
train from Southampton to Waterloo
Station arriving at platform 19 with my
grip that's what we Caribbeans call our
suitcase proud
I stood just a few feet away from where
the national wind Ranch Monument now
stands who were the thoughts that's why
I say to children and young people never
give up always keep hope in your heart
my lords today in every part of British
Society people are finally recognizing
the massive contribution the Windrush
generation and their descendants have
made were no longer told you've got a
chip on your shoulder
this chapter of our history is now being
acknowledged celebrated and studied in
every corner of the country
my book coming to England which I wrote
27 years ago is now read in almost every
school in Britain and it's more relevant
than ever today I get letters from
seven-year-olds saying they now know
about Windrush and they will never be
racist towards anyone because of the
color of their skin or because they're
different
my Lord's childhood last a lifetime
so this gives me a great feeling of Hope
and optimism especially when I think of
the time when I came to Britain and my
classmates relentlessly call me racist
names spat at me they didn't know where
Trinidad was they told me to go back to
where I came from at that time some
Caribbean children were even put in
schools for the educationally subnormal
because of their Caribbean accents
how about my laws
things have not entirely changed
unbelievably I'm receiving letters from
children who are suffering from racist
abuse in schools and on the streets
today
the way I had to ensure back in the 60s
some more education is needed we have to
fight this scourge my laws we are now at
a significant moment in history so I
would like to ask the minister what is
the government doing to further
encourage the Windrush experience to be
taught in schools as an important part
of British history we have got to see
ourselves to know we belong
was a national archives hold copies of
passenger lists of the many ships that
brought Caribbean people to the UK I
wept when I saw my name on one and it's
worth mentioning as the noble baronessor
just said that not only Caribbean people
arrived on the Empire Windrush in 1948
but a number of Polish people too and
despite also facing adversity they too
have made an enormous contribution to
Britain and should be remembered
this year as part of the windrow 75th
celebration the National Archives
formulated an educationally education
schools project to empower ethically
informed learning of British history
they arranged for me to speak on a web
Hall to over 15
000 school children about my Windrush
Journey which was so poignant yes who
would have thought
my Lord King Charles asked me to set up
the Windrush portrait committee as he
wanted to celebrate Windrush 75 my
commissioning 10 portraits painted of
Windrush Elders over the age of 90.
Windrush nobility who have made a
contribution to British Society in areas
like the NHS and to the economic
well-being of Britain across the decades
they are pioneers who showed us we now
stand on as they had to overcome
adversity and prejudices on a daily
basis in order to survive they have
paved the way and now they have a chance
to share the trauma They Carried and to
tell their untold stories through
portraiture the portraits were unveiled
at Buckingham Palace and will be shown
at the National Portrait Gallery for
seven months and become part of the
royal collection representing
communities Nationwide the BBC produced
a moving documentary about the project
connecting sitters and artists as they
captured the importance of this
important part of British history what a
legacy
my Lord's a Royal Mail have issued an
incredible set of wind Rush stamps which
I launched at the black cultural
archives showing how Caribbean culture
has helped shape Britain and the
beautifully designed 50 pence coin by
welder Jackson also celebrates Windrush
75 and honor those who have paved and
helped the way for enrich British
history
the king also held a Windra 75th
Anniversary service at St George's
Chapel Windsor for school children which
was truly inspirational the first the
church service at Southern Cathedral
bought church leaders and Windrush
communities together from across the
country how things have changed because
my lords when Caribbean people first
came to Britain we were told we were not
welcome in churches and had to form our
own black LED churches such as the New
Testament Church of God In 1953 which
now has 130 branches across the country
full of worshipers my laws this year has
seen jubilant celebrations of the
windrise 75th Anniversary as I believe
we must not be defined by the so-called
scandal in fact I propose it should not
be called the Windrush Scandal anymore
but renamed the home office Scandal and
they have caused the misery trauma and
heartache which still continues and
Still Remains a stain on British Society
with the unresolved compensation issue
of Windrush victims my laws I've heard
from numerous lawyers of the
compensation that the compensation forms
are so complex even legally qualified
people have difficulty filling them out
they tell me numerous claims have been
rejected based on inconsistent reasoning
and not fully considered even after
appeals there's a huge backlog of
compensation cases only 25 percent of
applicants to the scheme have received
payments and 93 of survivors have not
been compensated at all my laws many are
scared to approach the home office as is
also the public body of immigration
enforcement that that the threat of
which many have encountered without the
com the documentation to prove their
lawful status my Lord's trust has
disappeared and drastic measures are
needed to bring it back my laws four
years ago I pleaded with the government
to establish an independent body to
oversee the Windrush compensation scheme
my pleas and those of thousands of
others have been ignored so once again I
employ the government to consider this
proposal or perhaps consider an amnesty
and pay full claimants without the need
for the traumatic stressful and painful
application process the victims are
having to go through after all the money
is there
my lords we need to put the stain on
British history of the home office
Scandal and hurt cause to the Windrush
victims behind us once and for all the
Windrush generation and the and the
decent compassionate people of this
country deserve no less anything less is
an insult to people like myself under
thousands of others who have dedicated
their lives to this country and have
made a difference to other people's
lives my lords the Prime Minister needs
to show he cares too by engaging with
the windrash community and the Whitford
and the windrash victims which so far he
has not and public perception matters my
law is I'm an optimist though and I
believe eventually God good will prevail
but we all need to work together and
continue to build a solid foundation for
future Generations that's why I'm
involved in establishing a national
Windrush Museum which will do just that
as it will bring together all aspects of
lived winrush experience
my Lord I was honored to represent the
Windrush generation and carry the
scepter of Dove representing equality
spirituality and mercy at King Charles's
diverse and inclusive coronation which I
believe is a glimpse into the future so
here's to more glorious all-embracing
British historic windrust celebrations
in years to come
my lords it is an honor but also a
challenge to follow such an
inspirational speech by the noble lady
Benjamin
it is wonderful
that a ship which is it is believed was
named after a river in the Cotswolds is
now synonymous with a generation of
mainly Caribbean people coming to the UK
to make it their home
and what a celebration it has been over
the last few years three quarters of a
million pounds for Community
celebrations the wonderful monument that
many have spoken of in Waterloo Station
and the 10 beautiful portraits
commissioned by his majesty the king
even walking home last night one of
those portraits of Alfred gone was on
the digital advertising hoarding as I
passed by a bus stop
I suppose my lords though I might be
biased as although brought up in rural
then monoracial Rutland I have lived in
Trinidad and Tobago a food a culture
aligning with friends and a freedom in
expressing your worship of God that I
still so deeply appreciate
however my Lord the presence of my Noble
friend from the home office alongside
the noble baroness lady Scot from
communities and leveling up reminds us
that this celebration has been tinged
with sadness
like many churches in the 1950s and 60s
the home office has not always treated
the Windrush generation justly or kindly
there was of course a black community
already in the UK in fact the first
black lead Church Sumner Road Chapel was
established in Peckham in 1906 such were
the numbers living here but Windrush was
of course Mass migration which would
change the UK and I believe for the
better
but Noble Lords I was also reminded
recently by a British Jamaican friend
that the reason his parents moved here
was that they believed that there were
no opportunities for the family
especially for the children back in
Jamaica
the way the British were ruling Jamaica
at that time as it was 14 years after
Windrush that Jamaica won its
independence did not give some
confidence in the future for their
children
and of course so many did make a great
future for their children and
grandchildren and although early
Windrush migrants faced harsher
discrimination than today sadly some
still exist
the data from the commission on racial
and ethnic minority disparity report
from 2021 outlined that there are still
issues and persistent issues
particularly in terms of Education
into I'm quoting now in terms of overall
progression black Caribbean pupils are
the least likely of the main ethnic
groups to progress to the more Elite
High tariff universities by the age of
19.
this progression rate of 5.2 percent is
less than half of the overall National
figure of 10.9 for all pupils of the
main ethnic groups the black Caribbean
group is the least likely to attend
University at all after the white
British group
new evidence indicates that the
attainment obviously in education is
closely related to socioeconomic status
a topic in the headlines at the moment
but once that factor is controlled for
all major ethnic groups perform better
than white British pupils except for
black Caribbean pupils so I'd be
grateful if my Noble friend the minister
could obtain an answer or could answer
the question I have previously raised in
your lordship's house as to whether a
specific Windrush scholarships for
higher tariff universities and also
Windrush apprenticeships could be
founded although there are many other
issues that need to be addressed to deal
with such educational disparities this
would be an important marker
of course there is a tenacity within
this within communities as despite these
educational disparities and perhaps due
to the length of the presence here in
the UK being the first mass migration of
the 20th century and I'm quoting again
from the report young people from the
black Caribbean group have a much lower
unemployment rate than those from black
African ethnic groups even though the
Prejudice faced by both groups is likely
to be of equal measure
and although
also along with other Noble Lords I I
think it's good to to believe that the
scheme is not going to close but I do
also agree what positive action is being
taken by the home office to find the
claimants not only to improve the
processes I do pay tribute to the work
in the face of much scrutiny that civil
servants have done and perhaps I boldly
say that the only
uncontroversial fact of the of the
scheme has been its co-chair Bishop
Derek Webley of the New Testament Church
of God that the noble Lady Lady Benjamin
mentioned who has worked honorably on
such a controversial project
so I do hope that all the claimants will
be found and so the scheme can fade from
our memory as it is rather a cloud on an
otherwise wonderful 75-year anniversary
so my lords whilst we celebrate deeply
the amazing people of the Windrush
generation for some though
there is a haunting of dislocation
dislocation from West Africa dislocation
from the Caribbean an additional
dislocation whilst living in the UK
we are only now beginning to understand
the generational impacts
for human communities of the severing of
ties to land communities culture and
language
the generational effects of trauma for
indigenous people for for survivors of
the Holocaust might actually according
to research even be carried in the DNA
we are all the Richer and blessed for
the UK Windrush generation but let's
never forget the cost and the suffering
over many centuries
in other words in the time available I
intend to confine my comments largely to
the windrust compensation Arrangements
which have been the subject of debate in
this house on a number of occasions
the independent Williams review Into the
windrust Scandal stated that it was
quote foreseeable and avoidable close
quote
the compensation scheme is intended to
compensate claimants for the losses and
adverse impacts suffered
the original impact assessment said that
there was quote significant uncertainty
surrounding the volume of claims and
Associated costs those quote and that
quote compensation and operational costs
are estimated in line with the 11 500
editable claimants planning assumptions
close quote and total compensation costs
range from 20.5 million to
301.3 million based on the volume range
of 3 000 to 15 000 eligible claims with
a best estimate of 160.9 million close
quote
those figures and the wide disparity
they indicate revealed that the
government hadn't a clue
about the size of the issue they faced
at that time
and indeed since then the projected
estimated number of claimants has fallen
dramatically and somewhat faster than
the rate of inflation
could the government say what their
latest estimate is of the total number
of likely eligible claims and how they
have come to the conclusion that this is
the likely figure
but what the government were pretty sure
about was that the average compensation
payment
should be since the original planning
Assumption of 11 500 eligible claimants
was going to give rise to estimated
compensation costs of 160.9 million
on average payment of some 14
000 pounds
a worryingly low and miserly figure as
has been argued in previous Windrush
debates
there's a reminder ourselves that these
compensation payments are intended to
cover losses ranging from detention and
removal loss of employment loss of
housing loss of Access to Health Care
lost education loss of access to Banking
and what is described as impact on
normal daily life which apparently
includes for example missed key family
events or inability to travel
and included in that must also be the
feelings of rejection humiliation and
Injustice of something being told
wrongly that you have no status and no
right to remain in or return to the
country you've lived in for much if not
all of your life the country you proudly
regarded as your home in the same way as
members of your lordship's house do
is all that worth compensation of
initially on average fourteen thousand
pounds which Under Pressure the
government now appear to have been
shamed into raising to 37 500 on average
on the basis of the most recent figures
following changes to the compensation
scheme in December 2020 and August 2022
but let's get this into perspective
a recent former prime minister and there
now been quite a few recent former Prime
Ministers once infamously described
payment of 250 000 pounds per annum for
his newspaper column as quote peanuts
close quote 37 500 pounds is around a
seventh of quote peanuts foes quote
when it comes to the level of
compensation we're not talking about
some relatively minor event where
someone got hurt
I'm aware for example of a personal
injury case involving no loss of income
and no hospitalization as an inpatient
but instead loss of three teeth and
bruising which resulted in Damages and
compensation of some twenty two and a
half thousand pounds
compared to that on the windrust
generation Wendy Williams said and I
quote the many stories of Injustice and
hardship are heartbreaking with jobs
lost lives uprooted and Untold Damage
Done to so many individuals and their
families quote unquote they had no
reason to doubt their status that they
belonged in the UK close quote
can the government in their response
indicate what was the Benchmark against
which they determined that the
fluctuating levels of compensation we're
talking about
initially on average of 14
000 now on average of 37 and a half
thousand are fair and reasonable and
should not be higher in the light of the
powerful words in the Williams reviews
which I have just referred
the compensation has been withdrawn up
to save the government money
since the original impact assessment
States Under The Heading benefits of the
compensation scheme that quote the
government will also mitigate the risk
of litigation and Associated legal costs
which is likely to be more expensive
than compensation through the scheme
close quote
the low level of compensation payments
also reflects the government's hostile
environment policy and its austerity
program
in 2012 the then Home Secretary Teresa
may said and I quote the aim is to
create here in Britain a really hostile
environment for illegal migration close
quote
clearly the then conservative-led
coalition government didn't believe any
previous government had pursued what
they would deem a really hostile
environment policy
Wendy Williams lessons have earned
review report said and I quote the
expansion of the hostile environment
from 2014 would increase the reach of
immigration controls beyond the home
office including through increased
demands for documentation to prove
status which would ultimately lead to
the British people being caught up in
enforcement of measures
a review also stated that and I quote
again the impact assessment for the
Bills leading to the 2014 and 2016
immigration acts didn't go far enough to
identify or address possible risks of
the proposed hostile environment
policies
and indeed the permanent secretary at
the home office confirmed the inadequacy
of the development's impact assessments
when he spoke to the Public Accounts
committee about the windrust Scandal on
the 17th of December 2018 as follows
quote I completely agree that we should
have spotted this issue it should have
appeared in our impact assessments we
should have understood the potential
adverse effect of these policies on this
population I completely agree with that
close quote
everywhere you look you find that the
windrust generation were let down and
badly treated by government and
particularly the home office
if we were talking about more powerful
than influential claimants who have been
treated in the same way as the windrust
generation
would we be talking about an average
compensation payment of just 37 and a
half thousand
I wish I could say yes but I cannot
indeed would we still be talking or
would the matter have been dealt with
and finalized a long time ago
would the position have been the same if
the overwhelming majority of claimants
had been White
I hope the answer is yes
Wendy Williams told the home Affairs
select committee on October in October
2020 quote this is an opportunity for
the home office to demonstrate that it's
taking things seriously
if 164 people have been recompensed they
struggle to see how the department can
justify that close quote
nearly three years on the home office
say that under two-thirds of far less
than expected claims have had a final
decision not exactly meteoric progress
I have some questions in relation to
compensation payments
the government has said that the
compensation scheme allows those who've
suffered to avoid Court proceedings in
pursuit of Justice
could the government say in their
response if an individual accepting a
final offer of compensation under the
scheme does or does not then preclude
themselves from pursuing the matter
further through legal proceedings if
that is a step they wish to explore
since there have been changes made in
the compensation scheme since Awards of
compensation started to be made can the
government say whether those who
received an accepted final offers before
the December 2020 and August 2022
compensation scheme changes were brought
into effect
have had their compensation increased to
fully reflect the impact those changes
would have had on the compensation
offers they received and accepted
how many people in this category had
their compensation increased as a result
and how many if any did not
what percentage of any of windrust
compensation scheme settlements have
been subject to confidentiality
agreements in the last year and why
and how many current Windrush
compensation claims if any have been in
process for over 18 months
there was provision for an independent
review by an hmrc adjudicator where a
claimant is not satisfied with the
outcome of their case
is that still the position and if so is
it still the case the home office can
then reject a recommendation of an
independent reviewer
if so how many cases have been referred
to The Independent adjudicator in how
many cases is the adjudicator increase
the level of compensation
and in how many cases of the home office
rejected a recommendation of the
independent adjudicator
rejecting recommendations is now an
increasing feature of the government's
approach
on the 26th of January 2023 the Home
Secretary announced that the government
would not be implementing three of the
30 recommendations of the woodlands
review now I seem to recollect the
government having previously told this
house
that it was good news that all of the 30
recommendations have been accepted
if I'm right can I take it that the
government's position is that it is now
bad news that only 27 of the 30
recommendations have been accepted
the three recommendations that are not
now going to be implemented relate to
running a program of reconciliation
events with members of the Windrush
generation appointing a migrants
commissioner and reviewing the remitting
role of the independent Chief Inspector
of borders and immigration
Wendy Williams response was and I quote
I am disappointed that the department
has decided not to implement what I see
as The crucial external scrutiny
measures namely my recommendations
related to the migrants commissioner and
the icibi as I believe they will raise
the confidence of the Windra community
and also help the department succeed as
it works to protect the wider public of
whom the windrust generation is such an
important part close quote
one inevitably suspects that the present
Home Secretary saw the migrants
commissioner and an increased role for
the Chief Inspector of borders and
immigration as a potential source of
Challenge and criticism of government
actions and policy
it's most unlikely that the decision was
driven by what was best for the public
including the windrust generation rather
than what was in the best interest of
the Home Secretary and the government
many fine words have already been said
in this debate about the massive
contribution of the Windrush generation
to life in this country
perhaps we should also express our
appreciation by looking again at the
level of compensation payments which
just do not seem to reflect the effects
of what Wendy Williams described as the
heartbreaking stories of ingested and
hardship with jobs lost lives uprooted
and Untold Damage Done to so many
individuals and Families
I'm asking the government to look again
at the level of compensation payments
and I await a response in their
concluding reply at the end of this
debate
my Lord so I'm grateful to his Majesty's
government for the opportunity to debate
this very important anniversary
on the 22nd of June I had the privilege
of welcoming together with the
Archbishop of the province of the West
Indies to the national service at
Southern Cathedral the Royal highnesses
the Duke and Duchess of Gloucester
bishops from the Caribbean and from
England other church leaders members of
the community and prominently members of
the Windrush generation themselves and
their descendants
it was a witness and Thanksgiving to 75
years of change in Britain the
contribution those pioneers made how we
have changed as a nation and the burdens
we have made that generation better
the previous week my lords I attended a
reception hosted by his majesty the king
at Buckingham Palace at which the
portraits he had commissioned which we
have heard of members of the Windrush
generation were exhibited
we not only marveled at the art but met
both sitters and artists
as many of your Lordships will know the
King has previously commissioned series
of portraits down the years for those
engaged variously in the Battle of
Britain the D-Day Landings and those who
survived the Holocaust
in each case we witness in paint people
who are the product of extraordinary
lives and whose essential character is
distilled onto canvas for future
generations to remember to interpret and
to cherish
this latest exercise in portraiture my
lords now an exhibition in the Royal
Palace of Hollywood while each of our
different artists has a common feature
of the miracle of human personality into
old age something I'm sure this house
will appreciate
many convey extraordinary power and joy
others are quiet strength with struggles
along the way chiseled into their
features
what portraiture does my Lord says to
remind us of the intensely personal
nature of life away from the great
Aggregates that normally determine
policy
here are lives that speak of what
governments and communities did in the
past and how we treat them now
it further reminds me my lords of
photographic exhibitions the first at
the Oxo tower on the South Bank marking
the 70th anniversary of Windrush by the
photographer Jim Grover and a current
exhibition also by him at Clapham
library in the Mary Seacole Center on
Clapham High Street until September
it includes an image of the war memorial
to African and Caribbean service people
of two world wars that was installed in
2017 in windrash square in Brixton in
the heart of the global Diocese of
southwark
baroness Benjamin has spoken of The
Magnificent Windrush Monument unveiled
last year at Waterloo
that my lords is really where we come in
with Windrush
the Empire Windrush was a prize of War a
German liner renamed after a river in
the Cotswolds returning Maniac
servicemen for many of the Caribbean
Travelers on board had served in the RAF
to Britain whose factors mines and
services faced shortages and whose
infrastructure was worn out or in Ruins
they were adventurous but not needy the
fair was 28 pounds 10 Shillings and it
has ran out to find a group such as your
Lordships house that knows what I mean
when I say 10 Shillings
a substantial amount for the average
industrial earnings was then less than
six pounds a week
the colonial office billeted them in my
diocese in a deep shelter at Clapham
South and the nearest labor exchange was
in Cold Harbor Lane in Brixton
hence the association with the area was
established
they received a warm welcome from the
nearby church of Saint John Angel town
would that all the churches our friends
visited had extended them the same
welcome in many they were rejected sadly
that was not to be their experience of
Welcome a cause of lament shame and
sorrow
the legacy of the last 75 years my lords
is still with us
there is still disproportionate outcomes
for which there is no ready or
reasonable explanation
the instance of what we call the
Windrush scandal
Amelia gentleman of the Guardian
newspaper had been publishing articles
setting up the problem with unsettling
Clarity for months it is good that her
book is in the chamber
the immediate proximity of the
Commonwealth heads of government meeting
in April 2018
made it impossible to ignore what she
was saying the home office and prime
minister made a public acknowledgment of
the wrongs that needed to be righted
yet we need to note my lords that of
those affected only one in four who have
applied to the compensation scheme has
received any compensation
Lord Ross's speech is telling 41
individuals who made an application have
died while waiting for their claims to
be processed
it is worth reminding ourselves my Lord
that the imposition of what was
originally deemed to be a hostile
environment by legislation in 2014 and
16 requiring proof of a right to remain
has deprived individuals of jobs homes
benefits and their health
in at least 83 cases the final total is
unknown individuals with the right of
Abode or indefinite leave to remain were
unlawfully deported by the government
etisals one official has recently
remarked the crumbling of lives as the
weight of unfairness and impossibility
is forced upon them
to have to provide some of the very same
documentations that was demanded to
prove a right to remain in order to
receive compensation does my lords lead
me to deep concern
it is also a matter of regret my Lord so
the current Home Secretary decided to
drop the government's commitment to
follow through on the recommendations
from the Williams inquiry to establish a
migrants commissioner that is surely
needed
reconciliation events also have been
dropped and to strengthen the powers of
the independent Chief Inspector of
borders and immigration
a commitment made is better when it is
honored
my lords I am grateful once again to the
government for facilitating this debate
on a remarkable generation who had
changed this country for the better
those of us who live in the midst of
great diversity need to articulate A
Narrative of appreciation and respect
for the contribution of those who have
helped us become the nation and people
we are equal in dignity humanity and
status in this United Kingdom of
different nations and peoples
we encourage the government to widen its
Declaration of appreciation
to express a much deeper appreciation of
the positive benefits of immigration
which has in so many ways blessed and
enriched and changed our national life
and identity
thank you my Lord it is real honor to
follow Bishop of solid
I thank the Nova Lord Murray for
bringing this motion to this house my
lords it is indeed a real privilege and
an honor to take part in this debate
this is a romantic momentous occasion
the 75th anniversary of the Windrush
generation
it is a joyous moment that holds a great
significance not just for the Britain
but also for the entire Commonwealth
as we reflect upon the past and look
towards the future let us embrace the
remarkable contribution made by the
windrust generation along with the other
Commonwealth citizens
the Windrush signifies more than just a
ship's Journey
it also represents the courage and the
sacrifices of all those men and women
who left behind their places of birth
and childhood friends the places and the
people they love so much in search of a
better life
they were the Pioneers the Trailblazers
who embarked on a courage
courageous Voyage to Britain after the
war
some of them had fought for Britain in
the Second World War
and when the call came they once more
came to the rescue of the British
industry
after the war after the second world war
Britain faced severe shortage of Labor
and in order to build this
infrastructure and the economy the
Government invited citizens of his
former colony to build to fill the void
in the labor market
men like my father who could not speak a
word of English but they had the guts to
get off their backs and sail across the
seven seas in search of better economic
life
to work in the foundries Mills and the
other heavy Industries
not only that my lords
they brought with them a rich tapestry
of Music art Cuisine and literature
creating a multicultural Mosaic that
continues to thrive to this day
their influence is evidence in the
diverse communities up and down the
country
the vibrant neighborhood that dots the
British landscape look at the Notting
Hill carnivals and a Punjabi Mela in the
West Midlands colorful
cheerful and vibrant
my lords if we reflect back the Britain
of the 50s and the 60s was on the cusp
of modern Enlightenment the new industry
the new thinking new art new architect
music culture avant-garde theater
Beatles and a mini skirts like someone
said the Wind of Change was sweeping
across Africa and Asia but still
but this is a big bot my lords
equality diversity and inclusiveness was
on its way to all the races but still
but still it was some decades away
racism Prejudice and xenophobia was at
its height non-white people were treated
like a second class citizen
they only did the jobs the others did
not want to do they were discriminated
in all walks of life
in housing jobs pubs clubs in every
other Institution
they suffered just about every human in
dignity
but slowly and surely they overcame
these indignities
today my Lord's 75 years later children
and the grandchildren of all those men
and women with a fortitude are enjoying
the fruits of their forefathers labor
they are at the Forefront of every
sphere of our country's life in music
art literature academic Sports politics
and running our beloved National Health
Service
as we reflect on this shared history
let us renew our commitment to building
a society that values diversity
abrasives inclusive inclusivity
and upholder rights and the Dignity of
all let us honor the legacy of the
Windrush generation and of the others
whatever the origin of their country by
fostering a future where every
individual regardless of their
background or origin can Thrive and
contribute to reflective progress of our
society thank you
follows this is a marvelous moment
where we can celebrate remarkable lives
great sacrificial people
or we can fill our faces with the tears
and sadness
of the distress they feel
135 years before
the Windrush ship came to the Tilbury
docks a great English writer Jane Austen
gave us the words Pride
and Prejudice
for so many who came on the Windrush
boat and the Windrush generation it was
Pride
to come to give to serve to sacrifice to
rebuild
to be representing their own dignity and
their own freedom
proud to help Britain reshape remake and
live again
but for so many others it became
prejudice
fearsome troubled traumatic
and turbulent
and ultimately incarcerated
I am a son of a Windrush family
my father came here in 1954.
he was a dental surgeon
trained in Edinburgh University did a
medical qualification then a dental
qualification then a dental surgery
qualification a long journey
his father
was before him a doctor not serving in
the Caribbean but as a missionary in
Angola where my father was born
so having come to the UK to train he
then went to Jamaica
in the little town of Savannah Lamar or
savlabar or Sav as the Jamaicans love to
say he met my very dear Mother now both
long past
he fell in love with my mother while
doing her teeth which is a curious way
to discover someone else's delight and I
always used to ask my mother what did
you have in there that was so
fascinating she never knew but they
married in the Parish Church in savlamar
and made their way in 1954
coming first of all
up to witness
a strange little town in the northwest
of England where of course I was born in
well dare I say it in 1958
my father practiced at 103 Albert Road
widnes
and I remember so very well in
1962 when I was just four years of age
walking with my mother up the High
Street towards my father's practice and
NHS dentist because those were the days
of NHS dentists and as we walked up the
road
and this was a gentle illustration of
the
travel that was around us
a lady stopped my mother and as I recall
the story it always comes back to my
mind I see every second of it
there's a little boy holding my mother's
arm it was a Winter's day she had a
classic old-fashioned winter coat with a
false fur because we didn't have much
money around her neck
and this lady said to my mother
holding her arm tell me
before you came here
did you used to live in trees
now we laugh at that now
but back then people's images of us
were not quite Savages but certainly not
sophisticated
that we'd come from poverty in order to
enrich ourselves and as well as the
nation
my mother's gentle and kind response I
remember it so well she reached out her
hand took the lady's arm and said no
dear
we lived in houses
just like you
and we walked on
she had that Spirit of I'm here to make
a life for my family I'm not here to
fight your ignorance
just a year ago at an event in the city
of London a lady came up to me noting
that I was on the list of guests and she
said was your father
pertain Hastings of uh Albert Road
witness and I said yes it was
she said well your father did my
mother's teeth
for which I am eternally grateful to you
and I said look at mine they mirror at
my father's work as well and we shared
Great Grins with each other
Pride
in service and support
joy in giving
Delight in creating a new life my
brother born in Huddersfield having then
moved to the United States to become the
dean of MIT myself remaining here
becoming the chairman Chancellor of
Regents University now the chairman of
psoas at the University of London we've
made life
but on the way here today
the Caribbean mother rang me
to tell me about her son
32 years of age
reincarcerated
for a minor
pathetic
minuscule error
in approved premises a man who served 10
years inside for crimes he should never
have committed however released last
year now back in
why because the prejudicial
discriminatory mindset of the system
didn't want to give him the grace of a
tiny mistake given all the progress he'd
made but the Assumption of continuing
Danger
that remaining prejudice
is what causes this fear of policing and
the criminal justice system
that remaining Prejudice I experienced
on Wednesday
after the teachers had taken their great
parade past Westminster Square had gone
up as they were striking it was
difficult to get here into the parking
facilities of the house
using my past which of course entitles
us to be present and not to be
obstructed a policeman barked at me in
an unacceptable way that I shouldn't
have moved until he gave me freedom to
do so I pointed out he had no right to
obstruct
he didn't like it but of course he
couldn't stop me
if I was not me
I may well have been banged up against
the wall
and that is the trauma that the Windrush
Next Generation continue to live with
and must be stopped
this is this week's voice newspaper
[Applause]
let's save our boys
this is talking about the fact that
black pupils are five times Caribbean
boys more likely to attend a pupil
referral unit and it's a virtual direct
line to incarceration and imprisonment
the department for Education knows that
the home office knows it and here's the
key figure one percent of children
Caribbean children
get five good gcses at pupil referral
units in other words persistent expected
failure
so we want to restore the pride back
into having been the people who came
here to build but the Prejudice remains
too persistent
as a summary on Wikipedia says of Jane
Austen's great book Pride and Prejudice
it's a story of girls it says who made
Hasty and rash decisions
and learn to pay the consequences
the people who came here as Windrush
sacrifices didn't make hasty decisions
but those who hold prejudice against
them frequently do
whether that's compensations or its
incarcerations or its referrals to
people referral units so what I ask my
lords and of the ministers here present
please
stop skirting around these tough issues
for young black men and women stop
skirting around the incarceration
pressures actually give us the pride
back
that was the reason for coming here and
building a nation of equality and
opportunity
my lords
it's been such a privilege to take part
in this debate to hear the testimony and
the descriptions of earlier speaker
speakers is intimidating
obviously in videos to pick out
particular speakers but I obviously have
to mention the introduction by the noble
lady banners Benjamin explaining how we
got here but I think we also have to pay
regard to uh what was said by my Noble
friend Lord roster in his extremely
powerful
explanation of why there is still so
much discontent with the scheme despite
what the home office tried to do
now I hope that I will be given for
striking a personal note
Britain London and Brixton in particular
over debt to the people of the windows
generation for all they have contributed
over the last 75 years
it is entirely right that we should
testify
to that debt in this debate
I mentioned Brixton because that's where
I live
and where my partner and I have raised a
family
hence my territorial designation
now for the avoidance of doubt I make it
clear that I do not claim to speak on
behalf of the people of Brixton we have
three excellent MPS who can do that so
much better than I could
but I can speak for myself and testify
to the debt that we owe to the windrust
generation
this is from my experience of living in
that part of the inner city than I am 40
years in an area that offers so much of
what London the greatest city on earth
has to offer
it is truly a Melting Pot mixing the
full range of cultures and experiences
even providing at the extreme a home for
someone like myself who started life in
North London
a truly Multicultural Society at ease
with itself Brixton makes no great
demands on those who live her you can
certainly be yourself now as the right
Reverend polite the bishop of southwark
has already mentioned
these things happen partly by chance
the arrivals on that Epoch making trip
on HMT Empire Windrush were housed in
clapping and so it was to the labor
Exchange in Cold Harbor Lane in Brixton
that many came to seek work on their
arrival later arrivals followed their
lead
they sought housing in the area which at
the time was cheap much of it was run
down in multi-occupation and still
suffered the scars of the late War but
it was available in those
pre-gentrification days
they did not just come to Brixton of
course but nevertheless the result was
and still is a special connection
between Brixton and those of the
Windrush generation
it has proved to be the center of many
of the events held to mark this special
time
now they have of course
been ups and downs stayed at least over
the 75 years and some parts of the story
are contested times were tough the
pioneers and the younger Generations
that follow had to cope with
discrimination and poor living
conditions they had to battle for their
civil and employment rights and there's
doubtless more that still needs to be
done but I believe as an example that in
Brixton we have created something
special that would not have been
attained without those who came on The
Improv wind Rush itself and those who
follow it
now
the noble Lord the minister in moving
the motion
in his
a tribute to the windrust generation I
think got it right
the words were right but of course it's
not the words we're looking for it's the
actions and I'm glad we've been rejoined
by my Noble friend uh Lord Vassar who
put the point so clearly what happened
is shocking which is only compounded by
the difficulties that have been risen
now I do want to raise an additional
issue the Frozen pensions policy
which has had a deleterious effect on
the large numbers of those with a
Windrush Heritage not all of course
but that simply goes to point up the
Injustice of Frozen pensions now I
understand I don't have the right
ministers here to gather detail response
but it's important to understand that
this is part of how people perceive how
they're being treated
uh by uh by the government
the policy for those new readers is the
arbitrary winners and losers approach to
making increases in UK State pensions to
those who choose to retire abroad
recipients in some countries the same
increases each year in line with those
granted to pensioners in the UK but
those in other countries totaling half a
million do not their pensions are Frozen
at the date they've moved abroad so real
terms their state pension Falls each
year the impact is substantial
simplifying somewhat the basic state
pension is currently 156 pounds a week
but over half of those with a frozen
pension of receiving 65 pounds a week or
less that's lost income each year of 5
000 pounds or more
now British pensioners in all but two
Caribbean countries have these Frozen
State pensions those in Barbados in
Jamaica are the lucky ones that there
are 300 with frozen pensions in Antigua
and Barbuda
thirteen hundred in Trinidad and Tobago
900 in Granada 800 in Saint Lucia and
hundreds more spread across other
Caribbean islands the Injustice of the
policy is clear but the government and
past governments have hidden behind the
need for so-called reciprocal agreements
we pay increases to our pensioners in
country why only a country why pays
increases to its pensioners in the UK
but governments succeeding governments
have consistently met for many years
refused to know to negotiate any more
such agreements leading to the entirely
arbitrary distinctions we see today
remember just to remind ourselves
members of the Windrush generation were
invited to live in and work in the UK to
help run Britain and they devoted their
working lives to this country it is
manifestly wrong to punish them so
severely simply because they have
returned to their country of birth for
their retirement
my lords um I'd like to declare an
interest as London step to mouth for
fire and resilience as I refer both to
the mayor of London and the London fire
brigade later in my speech I would like
to join others in thanking the noble
Lord the minister for his warm words
about the contribution of the Windrush
generation and to say I've particularly
enjoyed
um and feel privileged to speak in this
debate today not least hearing those
speak those Noble Lords speak whose
journey to this house started with their
parents deciding to take their families
on a journey for this country on a boat
from the Caribbean it is really
important to celebrate the pivotal role
the Windrush generation and their
descendants have played in the UK as a
whole but particularly to London and I
would like to agree with my Noble friend
Lord David Brixton is indeed the most
fantastic city in the world
um my Noble friend Lord Davis spoke with
warmth about Brixton and the rich
cultural and economic contribution that
the Windrush generation made to his part
of London
um in many ways his London is also my
London and I spent my Early Childhood in
southeast London
um uh with Brixton and Bricks the market
on our doorstep and as an adult when I
returned to South London I had the
fortune to meet the late Sam King MBE
who's already been mentioned in this
debate but who as my lords will know was
one of the first passengers to arrive on
the Empire Windrush at tilby docks on
the 22nd of June 1948.
um Lambeth town hall is clearly based in
Brixton and the welcome the new arrivals
received from the mayor there and um the
right weapon prevent noted that um there
was a welcome in one of the local
churches as well
um but at the Town Hall it was one of
the only formal welcomes that the
newly arrived
um people from the uh Windrush received
the local MP also spoke up for them and
not surprisingly many of the new
arrivals made Brixton and the
surrounding areas their home and their
descendants remain as we noted at the
heart of the community Sam King as the
noble lady baroness Benjamin said was
one of the co-founders of the Windrush
Foundation he also became the first
black mayor of southwark he was rightly
proud of his journey and of what he
achieved and it is right that Windrush
Square in Brixton close to where he and
other arrivals on the Windrush lived is
in the heart of that local community
in The Narrative of post-war arrival is
especially important to honor the acts
and courage and service that preceded
this especially during the world wars
which claimed the lives of thousands of
their compatriots while we celebrate the
story of Sam king and the stories of the
many others who came to help us build
post-war Britain the story of how they
and their descendants were treated is
clearly not one of which this country
should be proud we should and must
celebrate those of the Windrush
generation who worked in our hospitals
on our transport system and who made an
invaluable contribution in this
country's success since that first
arrival 25 years 75 years ago however we
also as other of my Noble laws have
already made clear need to recognize the
hardships and extreme prejudice so many
of those arriving on the Windrush and
later boats experience the Windrush
generation was invited to this country
but yet they faced and some of their
descendants continue to face terrible
racist treatment in the UK
despite these conditions the Windrush
generation helped to build our NHS staff
our air force and Military supported
londoners throughout London's transport
system and enriched the fabric of this
country as a whole through lasting
legacies in sport music founding the
Notting Hill Carnival and so much more
the prejudice is regretively not
confined to the history books in which
it should belong the Windrush Scandal
this government's hostile environment
which has already been mentioned has
caused Untold pain the disgraceful
treatment and then subsequent delay in
paying the conversation that uh people
are due is nothing short of shameful too
many people are still waiting for
apologies compensation and access to
Justice others have already asked for
clarification and I look forward to the
noble Lady of the ministers response to
the questions relating to this a true
tribute to the Windrush generation would
be for the government to implement all
of the recommendations in the Windrush
Lessons Learned review it's highly
regrettable that the current home
secretary has watered down the home
office commitment to accept all HMI
Wendy Williams findings in her review I
would like to ask the noble lady the
minister if the government will now
review this decision and meant all the
recommendations from this review
funding for Community organizations has
been a key part of the mayor of London's
response to the scandal in the years
since the Scandal first came into public
Consciousness in 2018 the mayor has
dedicated over a hundred thousand Pounds
into funding for Frontline organizations
across London to specifically support
Windrush communities this includes
dedicated funding initiatives LED
previously by the joints Council for the
welfare of immigrants and now led by
action for race equality
previous funding was used for a range of
activities including campaigns legal
advice sessions and Outreach efforts to
bring informational support to those who
may not access it otherwise
in recognition of the way immigration
advice access has been decimated by
successive cuts and in order to support
londoners to access their rights the
mayor has consistently invested in
efforts to bolster wider capacity of
immigration advice and support services
across our city more recently the mayor
has launched the migrant advice and
support fund which supports
organizations providing Specialists
holistic services to londoners with
immigration needs including people from
the Windrush communities this fund
provides three-quarters of a million
pounds over 12 months the greater London
Authority led by the mayor stands with
Windrush generation in their fight for
justice
the mayor clearly is also himself the
son of a bus driver as he says often who
also came to this country to build a new
life for himself and his family and
contribute to this country's future much
emphasis has been placed on the role of
the windrust generation in supporting
Transport for London The Wider transport
networks and the NHS the Windrush
generation had a much wider Legacy on
our city including among black
firefighters and other staff from London
fire brigade some of whom joined the
Walk of witness for Waterloo Station to
southwark my lords this house is
previously debated the culture view that
took place at London fire brigade no
institution in this country is immune
from needing to examine how it treats
those from black and minority ethnic
communities as to make a fire however
I'm proud of how the Brigade is tackling
this issue head on and playing a leading
role within the fire sector in
addressing institutional racism and
addressing the inequalities and
prejudices it finds no institution no
sector can be complacent and we need to
learn and adjust how we behave and how
we challenge behaviors
I want to reflect finally by my on a
more positive note a more celebratory
note to this debate I'd like this house
to note the huge contribution
contribution of the windrust generation
and their descendants to the Arts in
this country from the food of South
London to music and literature and
visual art the Windrush generation
brought a wealth of new musical styles
with them including jazz blues Calypso
scar gospel Latin reggae and their
descendants went on to Pioneer many of
the genres that are popular today such
as garage jungle Grime dubstep and drum
and bass in literature we have many
examples of remarkable writing and some
of this is now rightly taught in schools
I want to conclude by quoting the author
of the novel small island by Andrea Levy
herself the daughter of Jamaican parents
there are some words that once spoken
will split the world into there would be
the life before you breathe them and
then they altered life after they'd been
said they take a long time to find words
like that they make you hesitate choose
with care
hold on to them unspoken for as long as
you can just so your world will stay
intact for me this quote is a reminder
of how powerful but also how dangerous
words can be how they can heal and how
they can divide in this debate on this
anniversary of the Windrush generation's
first arrival in the UK and in a week
where we have in this house debated the
illegal migration bill I think we'd all
do well to remember the power of
language
speaking of the gap having given matters
and inspired to do so by the noble
baroness Benjamin who made a passionate
and at times justifiably angry speech
and who was herself very properly
recognized and made a member of the
illustrious order of Merit and there
could be no better example of the
Windrush generation of what we're
talking about today
it was also appropriate the the
neighborhood Eddie banners tricots who
just spoke talked uh quite considerably
the beginning of her speech about the
National Health Service and it really is
a happy coincidence that we were
celebrating the 7th and fifth
anniversary of the Health Service on
Wednesday of this week and we have this
debate today
because without the contribution of the
windrust generation and their families
the National Health Service would not
have been what it is and we owe them a
very great debt
but my Lord's there's been an underlying
theme to this debate
and it's one that I just want to dwell
on very briefly
the underlying theme is
really cruelty never pays
and
do to others as you would be done by
and I think we have to remember that
not only as we
think back
with shame
at what happened a few years ago
but as we look at the way we are
tackling problems today
I was deeply Disturbed to read in the I
newspaper this morning
of the painting out
painting over
the Mickey Mouse pictures and the other
things
that had been put
into
centers were unaccompanied children
and whoever is to blame for their being
here they are not
and it seemed to me a
deeply unfortunate
and frankly rather cruel gesture
and I think we have to remember that
as we remember and repent
for the way in which windows generation
descendants were treated a few years ago
kindness may not get you everywhere but
it does get you a long way
and it does help to make a cohesive
Society
and if this debate is to have any Legacy
it must be to make our society more
cohesive
more united
and more if I die use the word and I do
so with pride patriotic
my Lord I would like to open by thanking
the noble Lord the minister for putting
down this debate and particularly for
the tone with which he introduced it I
think the whole debate has been
uplifting but it's also been realistic
it's been realistic about the problems
that are faced and the recent uh scandal
my Lord's the arrival of HMT Empire
Windrush at Tilbury docks on the 22nd of
June in 1948 has become a defining
moment of modern Britain the ship
carried about 500 passengers from across
the Caribbean and that generation and
those that came after have shaped our
society whether by rebuilding post-war
infrastructure we playing a key role in
getting our transport Network
functioning properly or by supporting
the fledgling NHS
get the windross generation has not
always been treated fairly especially by
governments Keen to be
Keen to be seen as tough on immigration
but Windrush day and maybe this debate
should be taken as an opportunity to
celebrate those who by seeking a better
life have made all our lives better too
I first want to mention the will the
windrust Scandal and then conclude on
the more positive contribution the
Windrush generation have made to our
country
the Windrush Scandal or perhaps I should
say the home office Scandal was
recommended by baroness Benjamin began
in 2018 it concerned people who were
wrongly detained denied legal rights
threatened with deportation and in at
least 83 cases wrongly deported from the
UK by the home office
many of those affected had been born
British subjects and had arrived in the
UK before 1973.
particularly from Caribbean countries as
members of the windrust generation
as well as those who were deported an
unknown number were detained lost their
jobs or homes had their passports
confiscated or denied benefits or
medical care to which they were entitled
a number of long-term UK residents were
refused re-entry to the UK a larger
number were threatened with immediate
deportation by the home office this was
linked by commentators to the hostile
environment a policy initiated by
Theresa May during her time as Home
Secretary
the windwash compensation scheme was
launched on the 3rd of April 2019 and
there have been various reports
criticizing its Effectiveness and slow
rollouts
it isn't known how many people were
directly impacted by the Scandal but
around 6 200 people have claimed
compensation and 1 600 have received
payments around 16 200 have been helped
to secure documentation on their status
or citizenship
41 people who have submitted the claim
for compensation have since died
of the
2235's claimed in progress as of April
2023 16 had been in the system for over
12 months and seven percent have been in
process for over 18 months so I have
some questions for the minister how many
people are waiting for compensation from
the government how long does the
government estimate it will take to
complete all the active compensation
claims and does the government think
that processing these claims should be
taking this long
my Noble friend Lord Rosses referred at
length to um HMI Wendy Williams original
review of the Scandal and I welcome him
back to his seat and having had a a an
absence of about seven months
there are about 30 recommendations in
Wendy Williams report
and the government has not implemented
all of those 30 recommendations as we've
heard
the government dropped recommendations 3
9 and 10 to host a number of reconcilian
reconciliation events introduce the
migrants commissioner and review the
Remy remit and role of the independent
Chief Inspector of borders and
immigration
to include consideration of giving the
icibi more Powers with regard to
publishing reports
in January this year it stood at about
eight of the 30 recommendations that the
government had implemented this is
different to the figure which my Noble
friend Lord Rosser gave I became
grateful from guidance from the minister
about what is the correct figure
also the Guardian newspaper reported
that the unit tasked with reforming home
office post Windrush was being disbanded
is the noble lady the minister able to
say
um whether this is correct the that the
unit dealing with the Windrush claimants
is being disbanded
um
and can the noble labor Minister also
say whether there's any plans to enact a
recommendations 9 and 10 of Wendy
Williams's report
but my Lord
I want to talk more positively as well
about the contribution descendants from
this generation made to our society and
I've done a quick review of the Press on
recent press articles and I'll mention
some names
Micah Paris
singers broadcaster and actress Colin
Jackson 100 meter hurdles Olympus
Olympic civil medalist and broadcaster
Don Letts film director
J Blaze the repair shop host and charity
founder David Harewood actor director
Linford Christie gold medalist Linton
crazy Johnson poet newer musician and
activist Clive Mary journalist and
newsreader
sir Steve McQueen film director producer
and screenwriter Don Warrington actor
Lenny Henry comedian the list goes on
and this was just from a cursory review
of recent press
my Lord's my right honorable friend
David Lammy described the 75th
Anniversary celebrations as Bittersweet
and the noble Lord Lord Hastings
referred to Pride and Prejudice at a
theme in his bill in in his speech I
think they're both right in the way they
characterize these celebrations
and as an opposition speed spokesman I
say to the government that is for the
government to follow through on the
Promises it has made to the windwash
generation and to seek to rectify the
wrongs of the past
my lords
I would like to start by thanking my
Noble friend Lord Mario Bloodworth for
tabling what is a very important and a
very special debate
it is right that the house takes this
opportunity to honor a landmark
anniversary in our nation's history
I'm sure I speak for all us all when I
say that the moving Reflections we've
heard today from across the chamber
speak volumes about how much the
windrust generation means to us all and
the and that the mark they have made on
our society since their arrival 75 years
ago
I thank my Noble Lords for their
contributions today and I'm proud to be
able to add to them in this response on
behalf of the government
last month I had the privilege of
attending the national service of
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
at the right Reverend perlitz cathedral
in Southwick to Mark National Windrush
day it was a truly inspirational day of
music of prayers and of shared
Reflections on the experiences and the
impact of the Windrush generation and
their descendants
my Lord says included a poem from a
young Poet Laureate of Croydon Shanique
Benjamin who called herself a hybrid of
Jamaican Grenadian and Croydon
croydanian
which painted a remarkable Vivid picture
of the rich cultural heritage of the
windrust generation and their wider
influence
I can't do justice to her words but I
would thoroughly recommend watching an
online rendition of that poem
it's a poem that brilliant and it
brilliantly captures a flavor of the
windrush's generation's first
impressions of their mother country in
all its complexity
the sense of excitement as we've heard
today the opportunity to help Britain
rebuild but also the struggles and the
terrible prejudices they faced and also
the Monumental part they and their
descendants have since played in our
nation's post-war transformation
we undoubtedly wouldn't be the
Multicultural success story we are today
without all that they have contributed
contributed and continue to contribute
in every sphere of our national life
the tributes paid by my Noble laws
Testament to this for our part the
government is committed to celebrating
this wonderful world windrust Legacy
through National and through local
commemorations
my laws five years ago we introduced
windrust day in response to Patrick
Vernon's hugely Admiral campaigning and
I salute him again for securing this
Milestone around which we can all come
together every year
of course one of the most permanent and
we've heard it today and visible markers
of our gratitude to Windrush generation
is Basil's Watson's magnificent and if
you haven't been uh to see it please go
to Waterloo Station
magnificent national monument at
Waterloo Station in London it is
incredibly poignant to think that long
after the first arrivals are no longer
with us Millions passing through
Waterloo will continue to see this and
they will think of them and all they
gave
I can extend the biggest of accolades to
the noble labor the opposite baroness
Benjamin who spoke as always so
eloquently and so passionately in
today's debate as she always does and
for her work with my department and to
get this Monument Monument built
alongside the Fantastic windrust
commemoration committee and I thank them
all
this year's commemorations are
particularly special because they Mark
75 years of the anniversary of the
windrusher rivals and fittingly my
department is leading the biggest
program of wind Rush commemoration since
they began across the length and the
breadth of the country
in the run-up to Windrush day the
leveling up secretary and the Home
Secretary hosted a reception at number
10 to those thank you to thank those
working with Windrush communities both
locally and nationally Rudy page was
awarded the prime minister's point of
light honor in recognition of his
outstanding volunteering efforts
supporting Caribbean Commonwealth and
ethnic minority communities
we've also announced our largest ever
Windrush day Grant scheme totaling 750
000 in funding which is going to 45
Community groups local authorities and
Charities spread across the United
Kingdom and these brand and I'm glad
Lord Davis of bricksman is here because
they span the Brixton project a
community-led carnival of Art Theater
and music to the Blackstone black story
partnership which is putting on a myriad
of events from performing performances
of West Indian music to a book launch at
a commemorative Windrush 75 event in
Birmingham
and thanks to the National Lottery
Community Fund sponsored by dcms we're
backing a further 75 community events
and activities
but as Butternut Benjamin and others
have so passionately argued we need to
keep the Windrush generation Legacy
Alive by ensuring that young people
learn from and celebrate this and to
this end we're providing new educational
resources on the where National Windrush
Monument website
um have teamed up with the leading
educational charity speakers for schools
to organize a series of school Talks by
inspirational public figures from with
Windrush connections such as basil
Watson and the actor Patterson Joseph
available in person and online these
have potential to reach thousands of
pupils across the country
my lords as we move through the debate
and starting with
chakrabarti it was obvious that I needed
to um to answer the the questions and
the challenges from Noble Lords on first
of all the Windrush compensation scheme
um I won't mention all Noble Lords but
you know who you were and it will be in
Hansard
but my Lord's the home office remains
totally committed to writing the wrongs
experienced by members of the Windrush
generation
my Noble laws we recognize that no
amount of money will ever make up for
the suffering people experience so far
more than 75 million has been paid or
offered under the compensation scheme
and thousands of people have been helped
successfully to apply for for the
documentation confirming their status or
British citizenships
um payments to date include some very
significant sums Lord Rossa brought up
the fact that it was there were very
small numbers but over 240 people have
been paid fifty thousand to a hundred
thousand and more than a dozen people
have paid been paid more than two
hundred thousand and the home office
priority is to reward the maximum
compensation at the earliest possible
point to all these people
66 percent of claims have had final
decisions and the majority of claims in
progress are less than six months old my
lords and in response to again to Lord
Rosser only seven percent are more than
18 months old
however there are 14 categories and each
person's experiences and their
circumstances will be different it is
right that the home office takes the
time to ensure that each claim is
considered and is understood carefully
so that they can offer people the
maximum compensation to which they're
entitled
that says the comb office will continue
its efforts to reduce the time it takes
to process claims and the length of time
individuals must wait for their claim to
be allocated it is substantive decision
making to a substantive decision maker
is now less than five months and that's
down from 18 months a year ago
the home office is also committed to
keeping open compensation and
documentation schemes so it is not
closing the scheme is not closing it is
remaining open my lords
the home office firmly believes that
moving the operation of the compensation
scheme as has been suggested would
simplifically delay what we consider and
I know you consider my laws to be vital
payments to to the people
and and all these have been reinforced
my laws by an independent advisor to the
scheme Professor Martin Livermore in his
report which is was published in March
of 2022 and since the scheme's Inception
that home office has continued to listen
to feedback from all sorts of
stakeholders
and has made significant changes and
positive changes and improvements and
they will continue to do so as as more
evidence comes in
for example in 21 and 22 the home office
published a new claims form as was
mentioned by baroness Benjamin
um
in collaboration with stakeholders now I
know it it's a longer form
um but stakeholders are in agreement
that it is an easier form it is in plain
English and it's it's very much more
targeted and simpler questions for
people to understand and to to complete
and as I said all these changes that
we're making are being made in
conjunction with stakeholders
um the home office has a multi-layered
approach to reviewing the process
continuing to ensure that we have an
appropriate level of external scrutiny
and I know this was brought up by a
number of noble laws including lordrossa
and uh and um the right Reverend
president the bishop of southwark
the tier one review is conducted by a
separate team that has not worked on any
claim um so they are totally independent
the tier 2 review is an independent
review process with the adjudicator's
office and the home office has accepted
all recommendations made by that
adjudicator
I mentioned Martin Livermore he
regularly engages with officials and he
publishes annual reports on the scheme
and his second report was published in
May 2023 and that's on.gov.uk
and also the the home office publishes a
fact sheet every uh uh and it has
granular transparency and that's
published every month and that will
provide details on a wide variety of
aspects on both the casework but also
the ongoing reviews My Lord
um there was a as as I've said there
there is no cap or limit on the amount
of compensation that get the home office
will pay out and when the scheme was
announced it was assumed that a high
proportion of those that applied to the
status scheme might then seek
compensation and it is interesting that
although over 16 200 individuals had
been provided with documentation
confirming their status or British
citizenship as at the quarter one of
2023 experience has been that many of
them have not suffered losses or
detriment owing to being unable to
demonstrate their lawful status in the
UK and so they have not needed to claim
compensation
and but I think it's a really important
berridge brought this up that you know
we do we do um continue to um to
outreach to those communities to ensure
that everybody understands the scheme
and understands how to um to to contact
the scheme so the home office has hosted
200 engagement Outreach events including
120 of uh one-to-one surgeries since
2018 it's worked closely with Grassroots
and Community organization reaching
hundreds of thousands of individuals
through the um
through the Community Fund and it's also
run a national media campaigns and it
will continue to make those efforts to
reach for anybody that so far hasn't
contacted contact detected us so um I
think we are doing everything we can and
I hope that's answered a number of
questions but there there was some very
specifics Lord Rosser asked about
benchmarks and responses to the call to
evidence public consultation and public
consultation shaped my my Lord the
design of of the um the the of the
scheme we considered guidance in the
Parliamentary and Health Service
ombudsman's principles for remedy
on establishing time limited
compensation schemes and other schemes
of another
a good practice in that in that sector
the December 2020 changes increased
compensation under the impact of the
life categories to bring them more in
line with the judicial College
guidelines for the assessment of General
damage in personal injury cases so my
laws we've gone through the normal
process that we would do to look at
benchmarking for this compensation
um Lord Rosser and baroness weight twice
cross and the right Reverend prelate the
bishop of southwark brought up the
issues of where Wendy Williams
um three recommendations
um which
um
we Wendy Williams when she wrote her
report
she recognizes the challenges and she
applauded the home office response to
this Challenge and because of that as
I've stated
previously we have regular reviews the
home office has regular views and it
delivers the intent of all the
recommendations but not in in that
specific way extensive continual
consideration of how to deliver
at this scheme is is embedded in the
department and and throughout the
department
we the independent examiner of
complaints set up last year in response
to the Windrush Lessons Learned to
review is in place there is insight and
there's challenge my Lord's also from
the Windrush working group
and and there has been major internal
change of the culture and the
willingness to listen as policies
develop and implementation has begun and
we'll continue the home office will
continue to to challenge itself
internally on on its culture on this
subject
Lord Ross also brought up the issue of
compensation previously accepted and
when if if uh claims are reluctant and
yes whenever changes are made they are
reply replied my Lord's respectively
the right Reverend Bishop of prayer that
the bishop of southwark brought up the
important issue of deaths um of of
claimants while awaiting still awaiting
compensation and I think it's really
regrettable that any claimant passes
away before a compensation award can be
made and we we the home office does
prioritize claims where we are aware of
any critical or life shortening Indus
instances
um in any claimant and where someone
does pass away before their claim is
finally resolved we do work closely with
the representations of the state of the
of their estate which is normally
obviously their family to ensure
compensation is paid as as quickly as it
possibly can be
um baroness berridge brought up again
um what I think is a really interesting
idea that she's brought up before in
this chamber on a specific windrust
scheme for scholarships and she knows
I've passed this on to the home office
um and I I haven't had a response yet
but I I have promised her and I will
give her the response as soon as it it
comes through
um she also and so did Lord Hastings of
scary's book bring up a really important
issue of of the outcomes the educational
outcomes of of young black men and women
it is more complicated than than um we
all than it just all black men and women
it depends on on their Heritage quite a
lot that I know the DFE has done a lot
of work on this I know they've got a lot
of information on this I don't have it
at hand but I will certainly go to uh to
the DFE and ask them uh if they could
write a letter and I will put a copy in
the library
um I think I I may not have answered all
particularly Lord Ross's
um technical issues we will look at
Hansard tomorrow and my Noble friend has
said he will write with further with
anything further that we have I haven't
covered but my Lord's um
in conclusion I want to thank everybody
here today for your really powerful
contributions and and your tributes to
the extraordinary extraordinary Windrush
generation and emphasize the
government's unwavering commitment to
ensure that we never forget what they
have done for us in this United Kingdom
we are so thankful that those first 500
people made that journey and arrived on
our Shores on a day in June 75 years ago
a momentous day
they are a credit to their community and
to this country and it is the greatest
of privileges to be able to celebrate
and honor them today
the question is this motion agreed to
sorry that opinion will say content
not content the contents habit
s
okay
motion for debate reporting the
communications and digital committee